blind ambushes are an unavoidable part
of any Battle Royale game but it seems
that a new Call of Duty Warzone 2.0
glitch has taken that to its logical
Extreme as spotted by PC games n Warzone
2.0 players have encountered an issue
that causes their opponents to appear
totally invisible the glitch first
became known to the community when
streamer super Evan posted the gameplay
clip to his Twitter account that footage
shows super Evan being downed and killed
by an opponent who did not appear in his
field of view even though the killcam
clearly shows that the attacker was
standing directly in front of him the
replies to the stream's Tweet to show a
variety of examples of the glitch in
action suggesting that it may be
commonplace as of this writing it's not
clear what triggers this glitch or if
there's a way to counter it so if you
run into it we suggest emptying your
clip randomly into empty space other
than that there's not much you can do
Warzone 2.0 has been suffering from a
number of technical issues during its
launch period including a nasty bug that
prevents friends from partying up
however things aren't all bad a Call of
Duty fan booted up Warzone 2.0 recently
and discovered they had a very very
generous Double XP boost applied to
their account and they had no idea why
in a now deleted post Reddit user
cranberry khani asks of the community
quote can someone tell me how and why I
have a one year Double XP commenters
quickly replied that cranberry khani was
likely a winner of a Mountain Dew
promotion that offered up 12 months of
Double XP in Call of Duty as a grand
prize now cranberry khani doesn't get
double XP for every minute of the next
year instead they get one hour's worth
of Double XP each day for
365 days after they activate the token
according to the fine print in any event
cranberry khani should be able to level
up faster than MO most Call of Duty
players thanks to this promotion not a
bad perk for drinking some soda and if
you're curious just how many other
players cranberry will be leveling up
faster than the official Call of Duty
Twitter account revealed over 25 million
players played Warzone 2.0 in its first
five days of existence even compared to
Activision Blizzard's other games that
makes Warzone 2.0 a startling success
for example OverWatch 2 notched 25
million players in 10 days followed by
35 million players in one month
meanwhile Modern Warfare 2 continues to
be one of the most successful cards ever
with one billion dollars generated in
Revenue in 10 days it also sold faster
than any other game in Series history
are you one of the 25 million Warzone
2.0 players out there have you run into
any other glitches that we should be
aware of let us know in the comments
below and we'll see you next time for
more Gamespot news